es ist so absurd alles ich schieb da
jetzt gerade mit weiß nicht wie viel
Männer und alle Gefühl schie mit dem
Model aber wie sche mit mir für die
Reportage schaffe ich undercover als
Chatter of only Fans der Plattform wo
man erotische vöt und Videos Abonnent
kan verkaufen prlass GT Sache für 10
Frank bis zu 111 es Milliarde Geschäft
was hinter der Kulisse von Only Fans
abgt wüss die wenigste Agentur Content
Creator Models und Vertrag und man
Profil für me
Profit es W chetzt wo im nam von Models
mit der abonnente
schrie Ziel manipulativ Art sexuell
Bedürfnis V män maximal ausnutze zum mög
Content
Verkauf
Nachricht Schrit make so
hardxct al ist mit Abstand grusigste W
ich je gemacht habe im
Le
dan h das ist Mira sie jah auf only Fans
und verkauft erotische Content V sich
ich triffe sie zumick die Plattform be
kann mal zeigen was du so machst ja
sicher kann ich
machen genau also da ist ein M Profil
das hauptsite jetzt da Bio dasht jeder W
only Fans geh und dann wenn man mich
abonniert also ket 20 Franken im Monat
dann kann man min B Bilder und Videos
gesehen was sind das so ich ma so erotic
art eigentlich
so und dann h ich immer einfach ein Text
so
willkommenext Mira zwischen 100 bis 200
Abonnenten wo der
contentes Video so das ich ler
[Musik]
auf wer nur exklusiv Content V wett zah
zwischen bis 100 Fr proti oder Video die
Prise
mirber okay was only Fans so beliebt
macht ist dass man direkt mit dem
Creator kann schrieben üb Chat verkauft
Mira auch am meist Content und macht auf
dir Art am meist Geld wie viel genau sie
verdient möchtte sie nicht sagen seid
aber dass sie gut DAV le du jetzt nicht
irgendwie du jetzt nicht so sag du h
spezielle Verbindig zu den l wo du
schriebst so ich
glaub vor allem wenn halt mega schön
rückmeld wenn sich öfter mal meldet
öfter mal Feedback geht auch ja cools
Feedback und alles mögliche hab ich ver
sch also es bedeutet ver sch viel also
und W sag bedutet das der manner viel
ich weiß es nicht mit der ein nehme ich
ab be der anderen vielleicht nicht so
ist mega individuell glaub ich also mit
wie viel m W sag schribst du am Tag also
er war n Männer kan jetzt mittlerw viel
Frauen folgt
ich schrieb ich zeig auchfang ich bin
nicht interessiert mit so richtig Chat
wenn es Feedback geht für me Content
mega mega gern immer oder wenn so Sache
geht aber ich bin in beziir und ich bin
interessiert mit
L sexuelle Arzt Chat ich B interessiert
mit Content kreieren und der einfach zu
verkaufen also wieen mE lad in G und
dann verkauft mir das Produkt und
natürlich tut man mit der Verkäuferin
red und fragts Sache sie n dies und oder
ich hte Idee die und die Service od
irgend mega gern aber ich schrieb
nicht mit Männer dem S so das zeig ich
auch Anfang ganz ehrlich und das nein
das W glaub auch gar nicht zu zu was wir
sag wie unterscheidet sich only Fans
jetzt von Porno Seite ich denke auf
jeden Fall dem dass
es authentischer ist zum Teil zumindest
ich schaff mit das heißt es bin wirklich
einfach ich wo Text schribt wo mit der L
schrib wo auch mit der interagiert wir
Community wo hat dann von der Eik her
ist
halt zaht direkt der Creator also D W
sagen ist relativ selbst bestimmt ja
sehr so läft wie der Mira und VI andere
Models sie machen alles selber anders
Fans Model mir aber verzählt dass sie
em Content praktisch gar nicht selber
macht
abon andere über die Arbeit für sie das
ich nicht und so bin ich überhaupt Thema
undfangen mit recherchier was
ichfunden es geht zwischen Model und
Agentur und die Agentur übern schriebe
fürs Model aber das ma nicht Agentur
selber sondern sie Lager das
gostiter ich Mod und so mit
kommunizier funktioniert das genau und W
Kunde auf der andere Seite wirklich
nicht mit wem sie chattet all me Frage
Chatterin oder Chatter Stelle auf
Facebook finde ich l Gruppe und
ich mit über Mitglieder es sind
Chatterin oder L was no W die meistus
der philippin und T erfahr miteinand ich
frage 50 Gruppe für Interview zwei met
sich aber be Geld schlussendlich kann
ich die ein zü oh entgalt aber anonym
mit mir zu reden vielleicht noch
spannend was sie mir
verzählt aber die Familie also auch ihre
ma ihre Elter wissen nicht von ihrem Job
und sie verzählt dass das relativ normal
s das Chatterin der Job vor ihren
Familie einfach keint also ich bin
wirklich gespannt was sie mir mor alles
verzählt
hi hi hi Rob
hi can you briefly tell me what do you
exactly do as a Chatter I have I have to
pretend that I am the model my main goal
is to make sales but but we have this
technique that we should make fall in
love so will keep back to BU more how do
you make the spends as much money as
possible when I feel like he really
looking for something like a genuine
connection with a model yeah we call
them ways most of them are lonely and
they're looking for love how many men do
you have contact with a day so most of
them are just daily casual conversations
and I have to like tease them before I
can get sales all of them like 20 of
them think that they are the boyfriend
of the they actually believe I the model
I don't know how I do it though there's
a lot of psychology like you really have
to trick and play games right yeah maybe
that's my nature because I am toxic
myself how do you feel pretending to be
someone else and writing to these men
well at first I feel very guilty about
it I just feel bad when someone goes out
of money
money
have because they SP to much on another
one is I can't look at too much nity
there are so many
andiceds the nature of the job is really
daring so sometimes I'm
reallygling three different Sex Session
different i'll have to it because it
really well tell me how much
aurrently
hours days a
we wow so how do you feel about that oh
mentally tired i guess but and an adult
so I'll to it well thank you so much for
taking your
time by thank
you Victor % Kommission V all verkäuf
sie macht so verdient sie rund 2000 im
Monat was für philippinische Verhältnis
sehr gut ist aber ich hab Gefühl dass
sie das psychisch sehr belastet je
manipulativer sie vorgt desto mehr
verdient sie vikoria ist mit zwei
Agentur als Chatterin unter Vertrag was
sind es für Agentur wo so Chatterin setz
ich finde agenturin hab aus der Schwiz
wo bereit ist mit mir red ich sage Paul
sen Agentur 20 Fans Model un Vertrag und
ihr das Best bezahlte Model macht 25000
fr Umsatz pro Monat verzählt er mir h
setz i auch so Chatter ja das machen wir
nicht aber Teil wo gerade oder wo das
mal haupflich macht ist sicher so dass
Unterstützung mit dir W
h ganze
weltlich sicher ein großen Teil V V nost
und kleine Teil von fernoste
und dann ganzen klein Teil wous dem
dachrum kommt und wieso setzt man
Chatter i aus demativ einfach Grunde
wenn ich ein Firma und auch Mitarbeiter
Stelle will ich einfach nicht alles
alleIch handändler sobald Konto gewisser
Durchlauf hat gewissez abonnente wo W
mit dir
interagier kann ich irgendwann handändle
also es git es git
modfagen über am Tag und ja
duils pro Tag
beantworte hilft und das macht ch aber
den die verars mit der schrie und sch
mit aber Schar sch mit anders ja das ist
sicher bit
vielleicht richti wor weiß nicht ich
glaub es ist so
riesim lich und gichsetzt man sich
Konsument und und SEAG einfach ja mir
egal wenn
zurückchriebt die Konversation mit und
das ist Online Game das G es ist kein
dating Plattform ich l in der Regel es
ist Game und ich glaub
dasu sich noch beschwert hat ja der hat
mir richtig zureschrieben oder das Video
ich
mir anders geschickt sch das Video über
sich gewünscht hat das F sich gewünscht
hat und wer mir das züchbt ist mir
eigentlich egal aber wenn es den
wirklich wenn man so skeptisch wird als
konsumant und man merkt der konsumant
viel Gald we Gald denn eigentlich so
Moral schießen eigentlich und und den
den G wir manipulativ und finde ich
problematisch
hab also jetzt spann ich meine sogar
Agentur selber seit d es moralisch nicht
okay ist aber ich ma jetzt trotzdem
einer verstah ich das Abers Größe hab
man n alle zurückchrieben und es lohnt
sich einfach auch finanziell Paul s
Agentur nimmt 50% von all V der Models
anderersit mich Schw mit dem geschaft
bim Chat wird am meist Umsatz gemacht
und genau das Lager Agentur billig
arbeitskräft Victoria sehr von der
psychische Gesundheit sie
verzählt also ich muss sagen bis jetzt
ich mega spannendfunden so die
verschiedeneblck verschieden Personen
aber ehrlich gesag es ist mal wie so
wenig handfest das Fall wirklich so ein
ungfilterter Blick hinter Kulisse gerade
im Bezug jetzt auf die Chatter also was
für Methode wet die konkret da und wie
die Arbeit wirklich aus es geht jobbot
für Chatterin und Chatter für only Fans
und genau da ich Möglichkeit ungfilterte
iblck das Geschäft be ich bewi mich
wahrend Woche auf zahlreich Chatter
jobsfende erfahr BEK aber absag nach
absag die de Chatter Facebookgruppe wird
die nur ignoriert und denn wir die auch
noch mit vermindliche chatterkurs um 2
abzockt cool ich w schon fast auf und
dann telegram zugebot von kanadische
Agentur Person auf telegram g und h
Name ich jetzt da geschrieben und jetzt
muss ich allast da machen im erst
Schritt muss ich bewiesen dass ich gen
gut Englisch kann und schnell kan schrie
ich ma die Online Test und so r die wier
jetzt wird ich muss mit der Agentur
seing Simulation machen und BEK
zusätzliche Unterlage okay me
trainingcument
s was ma ich
jetzt ich studiere die
trainingsunterlage das sind 16 Scripts
und lernvos ganz genau so e zu mit wel
Methode Chatterin und
chatterwendet also ich habe ja schon
gewüst dass es so manipulativ wird sie
aber wie gezielt da mit dem männlicher
Lust gespielt wird und was für klaresig
alles kN al z. da seting face keep the
fan Hor and get Unlock many PPV possible
PPVs sind payperview also das heißt
Videos oder Bilder wo man den separat no
mal me verlangt make
sure PV Unlock Minimum und das ist nur
einon der harmlosere BPEL in dem leerern
Video wird's mir nur expliziter
erklärt
some a bundle and he unlocking them the
likeliness that he jerking off right now
are extremely high and if so if we send
them more PPVs while they are in the
middle of the action the likeliness that
they will unlock thinking is extremely
high you wann send Bund back to back
when somebody's unling a bundle
mit dem ganze WS muss ich jetzt die Sex
Simulation best dass ich z
Job nervö die er Minuten ma ich einfach
small aber ich bin recht unsicher wen
ich mich muss verhal das ist schwiig ich
mus die ganze die ganze Hinterkopf ich
muss jetzt
sexuell
aber da Konversation führen also muss
ich nicht her PUs nicht PUs dann bin ich
dann flü ich dur mus
ich
Part
body
cock love cos
babe love oder ha
babe you know love
Co oh mein Gott das ist so komisch so
jetzt ich schaff den schlussendlich dem
Typ wo mit mir die Simulation macht es
packages
vertick also der Simulation ich jetzt 12
also über
300 ich eigentlich
verkauft wenn die mich nicht dann weiß
ich auch nicht und tatsächlich ich
erfahre am näch Tag dass pa Tag
offiziell mit dem Job ich studiere alle
Unterlage ich
beauer die Agentur h ganze Akademie auf
rund um 16 fast Vollack mit auesig und
BP sie zitiert sogar aus vermindlich
wissenschaftlicher Studie alles das zum
Männer manipulieren für möglich viel
Profit der Chatter wet vorfertigt die
Nachrichten sie sag Scripts zur verfüg
[Musik]
gestellt
ich selber bekomme ganz zwei pro Stund
für meine erste offizielle seting
Schicht
so fangt
da was ob ich jetzt ein und schrieben
oder das jetzt nacher gefragt in der
nächste F Stund übernme schriebe von
zwei only Fans Models und muss jetzt so
viel wie möglich Content verkaufen also
jetzt kan ich da einfach mal in der
Account in und jetzt 24 Nachricht nicht
beantwortet
sind schebt eine hey
gorgeous ich check nicht wirklich was
ich mache weil ich bin einfach Nachricht
am abarbeit dem Chatprogramm ich muss
auch l was der Chatter vor mir
geschrieben h zum Gesprach nlos Kön
wierführen im gich schriebstil rechts im
Fenster kann man den alle Information
über die person I trage wie auch Kos
Name wo man ihm immer wieder
seid so wird jetzt Pussy
Videos und dann mache ich das jetzt in
dem Programm h wir Zugriff auf alle
Bilder und Videos von dem Model schön
sortiert nach Körperteil und was sie
macht min Aufgabe ist jetzt je nach
Wunsch von der Hundes Angebot machen wir
seht sogar wenn man
das Bild oder Video schon mal geschickt
h oder sie schon kauft h der pris da
kann ich selber definieren ich versuche
alles so zu machen wie ich s der Schu
gelernt habe also zerst es gratis Bild
schicken und dann erst die
Verkaufsversuch für
20$ D
masturbationsvideos und tatsächlich
nachdem ich ihn davor überzugt hab dass
es in Kauf mit wird
bereuen da tatsächlich 20$ für D
masturbationsvideos
zahlt
es füht wirklich schlecht
da sch oh my [__] Pussy so
pretty und das ist nicht die einzige
Nachricht in dem Stil oh man so
Nachricht scht make me so
hardx das ist so absurd alles ich
schriieb da jetzt gerade mit weiß nicht
wie viel Männer und alle Gefühl sie
schie mit dem Model aber wie schrie
einach mit mir wahend me erste Schicht
schriebe ich all Abonnent wo online sind
und versuche sie in das Gesprach zu
verwickeln die einfachste Variante ist
nach Script SC das sind vordefinierte
Nachrichten mit Bilder und Videos am
Anfang sind ganz kurze Videos oder
Bilder zum heiß machen denn wenn er die
kauft versucht man
immer längere und dürere Videos
Agent trainingsunterlage
beschriebt Typ eina manipulier dass er
Gefühl dass ich mich wirklich für s
interessier aber interessiert mich null
ich so vorspi dass ich mich
interessiere er nach
geh und m wend 20 Minuten schriebt ein
einfach s Sexfantasie auf har genau was
er alles mit dem Model wir machenam mit
ftis und Videos W sich einol ist das
sind dickp 5 und und 8 und und alle die
ungfragt wohlverstande AL mit Abstand
grusigste W ich je gemacht fr wirklich
was ich da
mache Typ wo Stunde immer wieder
schriebt an ich jetzt das länger Video
abot für 30 aber dann schriebt er mir
voll der Scham zurück dass er nur noch
auf dem Konto heigi er seid esag im Leid
er wird mich nicht entüche aber se Lohn
kan halt erst men nach seere sexueller
Befriedigung chattet er mit mir über
alltagliche und persönliche Sache und es
kom mir so vor als such ach die bezieh
was Chatterin Victoria verzählt Erl
jetzt
selber also ganz ehrlich am Anfang hab
ich nur irgendwie aufregig verspürt aber
jetzt ich warte ein draf bis da meine
Schicht ist ich hat nicht dass mich so
fest mitnimmt
irgendwie fast geschafft ehrlich se
wirklich kein Bock mehr drauf denn
endlich ist meine erste Schicht verbi
mit 50 m ich geschrieben und gerade mal
78 verkauft so einfach undreend wie
sulation ist es wieem n sondern ein
richtiger
Knochenjob und ich merk überhaupt nicht
gar nicht ich frage mich wie kann wir
das 12 Stunden am Tag 6 Tage der Woche
einfach so machen also es macht ein doch
kaputt am nächsten Tag Gang ich mal
Account von dem Chatter prramm da Umsatz
von beid Models für geschrieben hab Tool
finde ich auch dass die Agentur wie über
100 Mitarbeiter hat und über 150 Models
managed also offiziell wird Minuten m
die zweite Schicht anfangen aber ich
habe gestern definitiv genur gesehen und
ich tu jetzt die Person wo mich für 2
auf Stunde abestellt h damit konfrontier
dass ich ein Journalist bin und Stelle
ih no gerade paar Frage und mal l was
sie auf das
meinet also jetzt geantwortet die Person
okay aber fair also immerhin das Geld
was ich mir no schuldet von gester von
deer 5 Stunden Arbeit die dieüber wies
auf M Frage antwortet sie aber n und Rü
mich aus all channels mehrmalig
Nachfrage wiea E-Mail und telegram
antwortet sie mir n somit ist mi Chatter
abentür beendet es fallt mir nur nur ein
sach wo für mich nicht ganz aufgt only
Fans wirbt damit dass sie die Plattform
se wo content creators authentische
Verbindung zu ihr Fans KT aufbauen und
so kan monetarisieren das W ich jetzt
gesehen hab ist alles andereas
authentisch es git auch immer mehr
Agentur aber es GT sogar noch wier the
job only Fans agenturin hab wird jetzt
da auf Youtube als neueste und beste WG
propagiert zum schnell Geld verdienen
und dann gibt's da nur auf telegram only
Fans Model Marketplace wo Vertrag von
der only Fans Models direkt kan
abkaufen was seid also only Fans selber
dazu ih AGBs sind schwammig formuliert
und drum frage nacher was sie dazu sagt
dass es Agentur und Models git Chatter
setz ih erste Antwort ist so schwach
AGBs und sieine Frage a sie dass man
sich K beschw wenn Gefühl h man war die
verarscht und be den Geld zurück auf me
zweite Mail und bit konkret auf M Frage
Kön aber nicht und ehrlich Gag es erst
nicht we only Fans 20% von all
Transaktionen nimmt profitiert sie
natürlich auch sehr fest von dem
geschaftsmodell ich muss sagen nach all
bin ich jetzt wirklich froh dass Reise
only fansb mir um Gang zum so die abläuf
hin Lauf aufzzeigen dazu muss ich sagen
dass logischwies lang nicht alle Models
Agentur oder so chatteretz ich kann auch
ernsthaft nicht vorstellen dass alle l
Gefühl das Models mit Millionen von
Follower in selber wirklich
zurückschrieben also ich nehme kauft
einfach quiss Fantasie für der Moment
was ich aber wirklich schlimm finde ist
wenn Männer so manipuliert werde dass
sie sich verliebet geldd ausgabet für
bezieh wo einfach n vorgespielt wird
fürs Model für Agentur und mis auch für
Chatter ist das lukrativ geschaftsmodell
ich selber find es einfach ethisch
überhaupt nicht korrekt jetzt s
natürlich Wunder was meinst du zu dem
ganze schrib un
Kommentar